What's up with the caravan of Central
Americans planning to cross the US
border illegally? Tragically, it appears
that desperate people have been made
part of a dangerous stunt. El Salvador,
Guatemala, and Honduras sit in a transit
zone for illegal drugs heading to US
consumers who abuse chemicals to escape
there first-world problems.
Central American governments are
unwilling or unable to take on drug
traffickers who are flush with cash and
armed to the teeth. Vicious gangs murder,
extort, and force young men into their
ranks. Insecurity scares off investment
and chokes off commerce. Every day,
thousands of poor try to sneak across
the US border, but the caravan is
made for television, exploiting desperate
migrants to embarrass local authorities,
defy US law, and sow chaos. President Trump already has said he will cut off US aid,
which will undermine programs that help
our neighbors fight drug trafficking and
build healthier, safer homelands. So the
caravan has done a lot of damage,
dividing and distracting countries that
should be working together.
What do you think about the caravan that's headed
into the US border? Let us know in your
comments, and let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds, and be sure to like and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI.